because i'm so serious about your
success i know that if you work the
system and then if you get clear and
that if you put in the work and that if
you then stay too connected to a
community that's gonna keep that fire
lit that's why we've created it that
you're gonna hit your targets on youtube
and if you haven't joined video ranking
academy yet get into video ranking
academy the system is there for you the
coursework is there for you it is the
absolute next best step if you're not in
it yet recommit or join but work the
system
do you remember when you were in school
and they had those connect the dot pages
you know where you started at one and
then you drew to two and then to three
and then maybe all the way to a hundred
and at the end of actually connecting
all the dots an image was appearing on
the page maybe it was in kindergarten it
was a tree or a fox or something like
that but at the end you had created
something from nothing by just
connecting the dots and in today's
episode we are wrapping up a five part
series all about how you can go full
time take the leap to going full time
and we're teaching you how think media
the content creators here as well as
thousands of other youtube creators have
been able to connect the dots to youtube
success hey my name is heather torres
and i'm the host of the think media
podcast this is the number one podcast
to help you grow your influence on
youtube and then turn that influence
into a high impact and a high profit
online business if you are brand new to
this podcast i want to say welcome we
are so excited that you are joining us
on this journey either listening or
watching over on youtube or on itunes
spotify wherever you're consuming this
content thank you so much for being a
part of our community and what we're
doing here on think media i want to
encourage you to subscribe to wherever
you're listening to this content on and
if you're over on youtube click that
like button and let me know what your
favorite episode so far has been if
you're a returning viewer now today's
episode is brought to you by
growwithvideolive.com i am so excited to
announce that growth video live will be
back in person in las vegas in may of
2022. you can get your tickets right now
at
growethvideolive.com we have speakers
like gary vaynerchuk sean cannell omar
altocory and so many other speakers that
are being announced so soon so make sure
you get that ticket before we sell out
this is the top video marketing
conference for anyone who wants to learn
how to grow their influence online using
video so get your tickets now at
growthvideolive.com
now this episode is actually the final
episode in a five-part series that we've
been walking through over the last
several weeks i hope you have been
locked and loaded into this entire
series it has been so amazing to read
your comments on youtube see your
reviews over on itunes and it's been so
encouraging to see
how you are actually taking action in
all of these steps to becoming a
full-time content creator now we have
gone through the law of preparation the
law of momentum the law of sacrifice and
your business mindset now the first part
of this episode is actually a snippet of
a talk that sean gave at growth video
live this year he's going to talk about
that and then afterwards sean and i are
going to come on and have a conversation
about this action step that content
creators are taking that is actually
helping them grow which is connecting
the dots which is understanding how
youtube works and understanding that
trying to do this journey alone can be
really hard so let's jump into the
featured conversation and that snippet
and i'll meet you on the other side
[Music]
number five is you follow a proven
system
you follow a proven system this is also
like the law of the map like it's been
said that the time to have the map
is before you enter the woods right
like because once you get into things
and so so often our activity in trying
to grow a business or trying to grow
become a youtube entrepreneur is kind of
random and if i could go back and coach
myself
in october of 2015 i would actually tell
myself to do exactly what i did without
the distractions and the random videos i
posted and to actually not do a blog
and not even actually really share the
stuff on social media and not actually
worry about building a website and not
get too into worrying about my brand or
how i appeared or who i was in a photo
with from an event or any of that stuff
i would have went back and told myself
sean you already created the system work
it
and our system it's work it's proven
it's not just for us it's proven for our
community
it's the 7r vra framework what do you do
you reverse engineer you get good video
ideas you then research before you press
record you figure out okay how am i
positioning it what are kind of the
keywords i'm going after one keyword one
video one big idea you then record the
video and by this time you've come up
with the bomb title you've come up with
a bomb thumbnail you've really dialed in
what you're going to say in the video
then you release it the right way you
make sure that you title the video you
do the description you add the chapters
you do your time codes add the tags the
spots there you know launch the video
well and then eventually you rocket the
video
as your channel grows you could share it
on things like the community tab rocket
could include sharing it on social media
but to me rocket actually is internal
youtube features you do a youtube story
and you could share one video every
seven days internally you can reactivate
old videos in your library community tab
youtube stories which are
you know a whole nother thing maybe and
and so these different activities you
could do to rocket it maybe you go to
reddit because you there's a passionate
community there and you address
something and the only way you would
know that is because you're so deep in
that reddit community
that you are making topics they care
about and breaking down videos that are
viral are valuable and could go viral on
reddit then you rocket the video you put
some action into it then you review it
you look at the analytics and you say
what can i learn and how can i do it
better next time and then you repeat
the process and you get one percent
better at an advanced level you could
start doing content marathons we don't
even have time to go into that but i
think about i could have done content
marathons from october on my own videos
by the time i was in december and in vra
you probably know what we're talking
about but here's the thing find a system
and work the system
now of course i'm biased
but i want to encourage you like if it's
not vra it's got to be some kind of
system your activity in building a real
business is not random like your
activity needs to be strategic and this
is why i also want to challenge you that
vra fam remember i asked you if you've
been getting value out of out of growth
video live i need you to recommit to the
system to recommit to the simplicity of
following the steps to finish your
coursework 100
to make tony's tip of the week a
priority to watch the vra show why
because when you immerse yourself in the
system here's what's going to happen
after grow a video live hopefully you're
feeling inspired but inevitably you're
gonna get punched in the face next week
when you get back to real life that's
okay that's why we have structured a
community to help you win that's why i
need you to commit to listening to the
think media podcast every tuesday
because i'm so serious about your
success i know that if you work the
system and then if you get clear and
that if you put in the work and that if
you then stay too connected to a
community that's going to keep that fire
lit that's why we've created it that
you're going to hit your targets on
youtube and if you haven't joined video
ranking academy yet get into video
ranking academy the system is there for
you the coursework is there for you it
is the absolute next best step if you're
not in it yet recommit or join but work
the system
and so when you look
and now let's land the plane on the
power of video ranking academy
even during those months
even during october when i'm freaking
out i sit down and i go okay i need to
come up with a really good topic
i need to come up with a really
strategic video and one of the videos i
did
is what is amazon prime
and is it worth it
now maybe you would never think and
honestly this was on a channel that
didn't have a lot of branding or
strategy around it or it but i was
testing different ideas answering
specific questions
and so i came up with that video my
friends
five years later
this video keeps getting watched and it
keeps getting views
over the last couple years
it has gotten 639 000 views and it has
generated 2 578 okay well that's awesome
but what's really interesting about this
video
what's really interesting about this
video is the fact that you earn three
dollars for every visitor that starts a
30-day free trial of amazon prime
my friends
i i wasn't accidentally coming up with
videos like this and accidentally
stumbling into thumbnails like this i
was working a system i was starting with
the end in mind i was reverse
engineering get it
i was coming up with big ideas i was
thinking through things i was really
strategizing so i asked myself the
question what videos from my youtube
library are still producing results
today
what videos following this the seminar
vra framework and it's only gotten
tweaked and it's only gotten better but
it's the it's the exact framework that
i've been working for the last 10 years
i started to see that this was like what
it was and it's just got more refined i
mean it didn't have like the cool
graphic in the you know but i was like
working this idea of search based
content the power of youtube now watch
may 13 2015 this video was post posted
but the stats you're seeing on the
screen
are what this video has generated in the
last
year
and i have a video coming up too uh that
just so we have audio ready
so in the last year this video has
earned 50 more dollars in the last 365
days it's it's it's generated 70 new
subscribers for think media
and it's generated 13 000 views
it's six years old
and this is what it's done in the last
year on may 14th is a good couple of two
days um
this video has generated 173
in the last year
68 new subscribers so let me ask you a
question
what happens
to your youtube channel over time if
you're putting videos out like this
notice i'm also i'm not showing you it
doesn't need to be every video but what
happens
if you commit to consistency
and you have videos catch the vision six
years from now getting you views today
i also want you to catch the vision
because i know the questions come up
like i want you to go deeper into
entertainment channels and hear me vra
works for entertainment channels you
still need a reverse engineer you still
need to research topics trends dances
you still need to record great videos
title them well you could still promote
them out try to get them covered by
blogs the 7r system works for youtube
period
but not a lot of entertainment videos
get views six years from now
so my argument
is if you want to build a real business
that generates passive income and gives
you a business that can scale you might
want to consider positioning yourself in
some type of niche that you can create
content today that'll be relevant three
years from now six years from now eight
years from now
because i got 68 new subscribers on a
video that i posted by myself now that
we're in this era so i can say
i've never been accused of this but if
omar was like sean why aren't you
working i'm like bro well number one i
work harder than you but number two i am
working dude
sean aces 27 inch monitor just got the
channel you know 27 subscribers for real
every video that you post is like a
little baby you multiplying your
influence years later when you work the
system but this is the one that really
shocked me because in preparation for
growth video live this video comes up
october 5th
2010
and this video
in the last year
grew the channel by six subscribers
25
to the think media bottom line come on
6 000 views but in the last this video
is 10
years
old
and what i want to encourage you with is
omar called me out man and he was making
he was saying like look these videos
haven't always been good like work the
system where you are today like put in
the work where you are today put out the
best possible title and thumbnail and
video you are where you can today when
you hear all the content we're
delivering here at growth video live it
can lead to analysis paralysis it can
lead to overwhelm oh it's not as good as
i want it to be no ship the video put
the video out there i said s-h-i-p the
video in case you wondered what i said
put the video ship the video in the mail
get it out there make another one and
make another one and make another one
because when you post these videos i
mean this is that video let me play for
you here let's just check this out
[Music]
what is up this is sean with think media
tv and think international we've been
getting a lot of questions whenever we
go anywhere
uh we get a ton of attention because of
our
think video setup because of our think
setup because of our think setup the
camera set our video camera setup i just
wanted to give you a quick
okay do you see anything wrong with the
shot like if you learn anything from
omar like again i obviously have had a
problem over the years with the
backlight window situation like so so i
i could not be lit worse if you watch
the rest of the video
it's like i'm filming it it's super
shaky what i have a desk light on like
okay so lighting not good
even placement of myself by the window
not good like but here's what's crazy
is this video still grew the channel by
six subscribers
my friends if you put out videos like
this and there's still some powerful
things to it the topic is good
a a small group of people are still
researching these very specific products
and looking for videos and want to see
somebody show the video off show the
products off and so even though my first
videos were truly my worst videos
i was committed to the process and i was
committed to working the system see your
goal and this is what ends up happening
on youtube is eventually every youtube
video is like a clone army for you
that you put in the work and remember
like omar said he's like you know when
you really think about it and you start
with the end in mind you yes it takes
time like shoot i gotta structure the
video man i gotta make a thumbnail and i
gotta write the chapters i got to do the
things but when you put out that quality
youtube video to the best of your
ability
that's like one robot
in your army because the youtube
algorithm then that robot marches and
that robot works 24 7 365 even when it
seems like it's not working it's working
you got that robot working when you're
sleeping
because of the youtube algorithm and you
building up a mountain of views a
momentum of views and so here's a power
question
do you have a focused plan
or are you taking random action
and i want you to to say either make a
plan get a plan or we've given you a
plan
it's the 7r vra framework and there's a
lot of depth obviously in your course
that you may not have unpacked yet plus
we're unleashing a whole new
master's dimension of it that comes
after vra foundations this fourth
quarter that doesn't cost you extra
money we're just adding more to the
course
so we're continuing to work this system
to unpack new insights for you but
that's not what you need at this moment
you once you're getting a growth video
live you got to take action on the
information you have now you got to hit
record you got to take action on what
you have now and so taking the leap to
full time
preparation and practice number one
build momentum number two the law of
sacrifice number three a business
mindset number four and follow a proven
system
i want you to work these these are some
lessons i've learned let me know what
the aha moment was for you in the
comment section in terms of any insights
in which one of the of these do you need
to maybe focus on most
which one of these do you need to focus
on next
follow a proven
system man this is so challenging
because i feel like this whole series on
this journey to full-time freedom with
youtube how do you quit your 9-5
sometimes we can wrestle with this if
you have the artistic soul
and that's actually my background i mean
i grew i was a dj
i love art my dad is an artist he's a
woodworker and so sometimes you can feel
attention like well youtube's just my
play place for creative expression it's
a place for art i want to make the video
i feel like making today and who knows
what i want to create tomorrow and when
we start hearing system it feels like it
might be constricting it might be
limiting but i think you know last
episode we talked about a business
mindset again if we sat across from like
an investor hey investor
will you give me money for this youtube
career and here's how it's going to be
profitable here's how it's going to be
viable two years from now
one of the things that investor might
ask you would be like what's the system
another way to put it it'd be like if
you've ever saw the founder ray kroc
mcdonald's it wasn't like what kind of
burgers do we want to make today should
we try some experiment with the recipe
tomorrow it was like here's the plan the
beef comes from here it goes to the
place it goes onto the you know onto the
kitchen stove it goes onto the broiler
the fries go into the deep fryer that
goes into the assembly line it gets
wrapped up it's it's a system and that's
not to like take all the emotion and the
love out of youtube content creation but
as youtube entrepreneurs of course
that's that's what's key of course you
got to layer storytelling you've got to
layer your personality you've got to
layer all that flavor and that flare on
top but when you layer it on top of the
system there could be a lot of power
there and this 7r video ranking academy
system has now it's it's not a theory
anymore it's proved results for
countless students we have thousands of
success students and many who they're
nuances of their stories they're earning
10k a month 15k a month doctor eye
health over 20k a month um they're doing
laptop reviews they're doing uh eye
doctor stuff they're doing plants in
lucia mary you know one of our students
just
turned 70
and uh she was sharing with me she was
like she's doing great she's got a whole
business angle to what she's doing so
people of all generations all
backgrounds are using the key
is a
system they're following a proven system
and i do want to encourage people like
again if someone's listening to this
you're listening to think media podcast
you haven't joined video ranking academy
you got to join like but if you go i
don't know i don't know well then then
join something or figure out a system
because if you're just taking random
action you're going to get random
results and that is not how you go full
time that's like i might i might not who
knows i'm gonna do whatever i feel like
each day what's nice about this is it
really brings structure to your path to
full-time freedom yeah and i mean i love
structure sean so i'm like oh proven
system giddy up i love that but i also
do see that there is so much uh gary
vaynerchuk um he says that you know
everything on social is art and science
and the proven system part of this is
the science and psychology of someone
coming to youtube and why they are even
there and until you actually dive into
that and you understand why someone
there what are they looking for how can
how can you help them when you follow
this seven step process you actually get
to
see how how that big piece
can then be pulled out layers of the
onion get unraveled because you're
following a system for it and it isn't
just random but it is it is the art and
the science with it but when it comes
down to how do you actually do this
right like we don't normally have people
that come to us and they're like um is
this like i make a couple of videos and
get like super rich no this is not what
that is this is a system and just like
if you were training for a triathlon and
you have to run the miles and ride the
bike and do the swimming it's the same
thing you've got to run the miles do the
bike
swim the swing swim the swimming swim
the laps in the pool um this system will
help you to also have the art built into
it and we've seen that with ben azadi
who's doing keto camp he just did
another video he's made this video like
three times now the five best keto
snacks he's like do i make it again i'm
like yes why because it's the new fresh
art that you're putting into the system
that people actually want and what i'm
just so grateful for is that not only is
this just a regular it's not even a
regular system not only is this a
designed system it has the word proven
in front of it for a reason yeah and if
you're gonna pick a system prove one get
one that's proven get one that's
actually working for different niches
get one that's actually been tested and
studied and one i love that we do here
at think media is we are player coaches
we are doing this right now with seven
videos a week on our channel this exact
system it's not like we like got to this
high horse high place and we're like oh
no no longer doing the system no we are
teaching our team this system we're
teaching the people in our community the
system because the system is proven and
it works 100 and it really reminds me of
again this is all coming out of my story
i lose all my freelance clients in
october um and now it's november and
december and i'm looking i'm like okay
in the next two months i recovered all
that income
not because
one of the assets i had during that time
was confidence because i had the system
i wasn't like shoot i hope i can come up
with a good idea today
i wasn't leaning on just randomness i
was just leaning on let me go back to it
let me go back to the seven r's okay
reverse engineer what's the
purpose of this video how's this video
gonna make money
what's the purpose of my channel just we
we sometimes need that because i know
about you you know we can wake up a lot
of mornings i'm tired yeah i'm groggy
what day is it i need coffee what's
going on and sometimes we don't know
what to do we don't know where to direct
our energy i think what's powerful about
having a system when it comes to again
this is assuming your target is to go
full time as soon as possible
is the system
takes emotion out of things yeah
you know you don't want to run your
business off emotion that's a really bad
way to run a business
because some days you're up some days
you're down some days you're feeling it
some days you're not and the cool thing
about the system is the system itself
also does not have emotion you know
sometimes i know different personalities
this can be a a hard we think about this
when running a team like uh what i love
if you ever have a team member uh you
ever hire somebody or when you hire
somebody as a youtube entrepreneur
um sometimes
what can be ambiguous is if you're
meeting with the team member and you you
were to say hey you're not like really
cutting performance they go i feel like
i'm cutting performance well i feel like
you're not cunning and like what do you
mean by that one of the things that we
like to do is we like to have the
smallest box possible and it could be
something like hey we need you to edit
two videos a week
and so then the question is
did you put a two in the box yeah well
but i felt like when is there a two in
the box or not oh yeah but the thing is
what was kind of no no i'm just asking
you
did is there a number in the box so when
you think about the system the key here
being it was i didn't do 52 random
videos over two months i actually did 52
videos and i kept following the seven
r's i would reverse engineer i'm coming
up with the title coming up the
thumbnail and so i would ask everyone
listening to the think media podcast
okay
how many videos are you going to post a
week
sean you and heather say this all the
time yeah are you doing it but then also
are you actually following a system when
you post the video because yeah you post
a video every tuesday but if it's random
not effective not researched not
intentional not strategic it's kind of a
waste of time or at least it's just a
crap shoot it's like i'm pulling i just
i'm pulling the magical youtube wand the
power of the system is there's not
emotion there it's like of course
there's the art side there's the
creative side and you have to layer that
on top but you're like listen i'm just
gonna get up all right let me reverse
engineer okay let me research before i
press record all right let me record all
right let me let me do this do the steps
and then let me do it again and
it's not just my example now but my
example is two months later
i bring in 4 700
of on affiliates 700 over three months
so that's about 200 a month that's 5k a
month that is exactly what i happen to
lose from freelance clients and now
we're seeing people in the video ranking
academy uh someone today we just
celebrated on a team meeting she's a
doctor she just got her silver play
button yep crazy and so but it all comes
back to working a proven system does it
take time to build momentum yeah that
was the second law do you need your
season of preparation in your craft and
your expertise sure do you have to
sacrifice absolutely do you need a
business mindset yep but what's the
system
it works if you work it yeah and i think
one of the things that i am so excited
about is seeing all of the people who
are just getting started now so people
might say well is it too late to get
started on youtube
all these other people are getting
success on youtube this system works and
it works for right now in what we're
doing and i think it's just awesome to
see that you know throughout this whole
series um so many examples of people who
are winning on youtube and uh to be able
to go full time to be able to know that
at any level that you are trying to get
to um that you've got support that
you've got a team that you've got people
behind you with something like this and
uh really pumped for to hear the stories
of the next gen of content creators well
i love that she said that too because i
know towards the end of that talk i said
work the system where you are today yeah
because the other into that could also
feel scary like well i'm just that all
the ours are intimidating yeah like the
system's kind of intimidating my videos
aren't that good yet no remember that's
why that the last video if you're on the
podcast you didn't really get to see it
i played my video from 11 years ago and
it's totally black backlit it looks
absolutely terrible like the hook is not
strategic like it's a shaky camera but
yet that video still actually grew the
channel think media by six subscribers
over the last 365 days it earned 25 over
the last it's like that's like putting a
good investment in like a mutual fund or
something it's still paying you 11 years
later that's the power of the video
ranking academy system but the goal is
to just start with it yeah we
continue to go to new depths the seven
hours is like this loop you just keep
doing them and you keep getting better
better at them i don't think you're
they're exhausted you could always get
better at at reverse engineering you can
always get better at recording you could
always get better at camera so it'll be
overly judgmental of yourself today
right
uh get one percent better with every
upload your first videos are going to be
your worst videos you have to punch
perfectionism in the face and fear in
the face and just start you will
probably cringe at your first videos yes
you might cringe at your videos from a
year ago even if you've been doing this
for five years but when you just keep
working the system again you go okay i'm
committed to it i get it and
that's a good place to end this five
part series this has been fun i'd love
to hear you know if you're listening to
this on the podcast and you haven't
reviewed it on apple maybe you got a lot
out of this full-time series like how to
go full-time uh on youtube or maybe
you're just joining we'd love for you to
review the podcast you know maybe have
you listened to all five parts of this
if you watch the thick media podcast on
youtube let us know in the comments have
you been getting value
out of this
youtube is a marathon and not a sprint
and so
can we capture vision at the end of the
series what if you start working the
system today
just like i posted a video 11 years ago
and i definitely wasn't doing it perfect
i was doing it at like a one percentile
level like if think media is at like
full speed today i was barely i had flat
tires i the car was barely running i
barely you know had to you know prime it
to get that thing going it was barely
moving but i just got started i started
before i was ready and then i committed
to it
where will you be
two years from now think media four
years from now think media where will
you be 10 years from now and think about
how proud you will feel holding that
silver play button think about how
confident you will feel and recurring
revenue and passive income that's coming
because of the work that you did
yesterday i think that's power the power
of having a map the law of the map
man before you enter the woods
get a map
and if you
uh if you want our help that's what
we're here for because we have refined
the system and we continue to what i
love about the video ranking academy
seven our system is unbreakable we
continue to focus on that but we keep
building it out every week tony's
talking about quick tips we're going to
another level every month we talk to
another vra success student in the vra
show that is sharing their story of even
how they're using it we steal their
points yeah you know i remember when ham
radio comes on and tony just taught the
abc's you know and and i was like this
insight like because what we found is
that the system itself is so powerful
that you start putting it you get to
have your art and your it's not going to
remove your personality right it
amplifies your personality it's not
gonna constrict your creativity when
creativity works best in constraints
when you funnel your creativity through
the seven hours it'll help you go
further faster so we hope this series
has served you so grateful if you happen
to just be discovering the think media
podcast right now go back into the
library and you'll see all five parts
that
we've gone through on this journey of
transitioning transitioning out of your
nine to five making this your full-time
career we're on a mission to help 10 000
purpose-driven people create a full-time
living doing what they love while making
a difference in the world with youtube
and these are the steps friends so dive
into into uh these past episodes and
join us in the video ranking academy
well i hope that conversation left you
with something to think about and if you
want to join us inside of video ranking
academy i'll make sure to link down in
the show notes as well as in the youtube
description the best way to get our best
offer right now if you want to become a
part of that community and i hope you've
enjoyed this entire series if you're
listening over on youtube let me know
what has been your favorite topic so far
we love that we've been able to have
longer deeper conversations around these
topics that are actually leading to
youtube success and i can't wait for
another series like this in the future
so my question for you is what is your
next step do you need to become a part
of the video ranking academy do you want
to be surrounded by community and other
successful entrepreneurs who are
actually connecting the dots on this
journey maybe your next step is that you
need to figure out the law of sacrifice
and what needs to happen in your life
what changes need to happen or maybe
you're in the law of momentum where
you're just trying to make some
breakthrough and i want to encourage you
to stick at it because one video will
lead to two videos will lead to three
videos and over time you'll look back at
the end of the year and have 52 videos
that you can see are making progress all
of this is part of the success on
youtube and i'm so grateful that we got
to have this conversation together now
if you are over on itunes i want to
encourage you to hit the rate button and
then leave a review because that helps
get the word out to other people who are
wanting to figure out how to grow their
influence on youtube as well now this
review i'm not going to say the name
it's going to show up on the screen
a-l-i-t-l-c says seriously youtube after
listening to other people's youtube
information i found myself eliminating
their shows and coming exclusively here
i discovered the video ranking academy
here and the challenges and finally
understand how to build my youtube
channel it's really nice to understand
what i'm doing instead of just creating
and wondering why some videos succeed
and others don't i highly recommend
subscribing thank you so much for
leaving that information and i love that
you're exclusively here that you're part
of the video ranking academy and you're
taking our free challenges it is so
amazing that the think community is
rallying around this movement of being
content creators who are making a
difference in the world i want to thank
you so much for being a part of this
community for being locked and loaded
for this entire series and for leaving
the comments and the reviews and sharing
on social media it is amazing to see all
of you
digitally and i can't wait to see you in
real person in real life at grow with
video live happening may 2022 you can
get your tickets now at
growthvideolive.com
and i'll catch you in the next episode
bye
are you ready to start or grow your
youtube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com